so
hey you guys and we're back what's going
on yep okay every goddamn day you guys
yeah pretty much what was that
was that your thing did you not have the
the volume turned down yeah yeah on your
thing that's what it is yeah well
it's like i can still hear it though it
sounds like it came over there yeah it's
a ghost it's a ghost yeah that's what it
is or it might be the sink i left the
sink dripping so pookie could drink out
of it yeah no it sounded like it came
from over there and i just thought it
was i thought it was excellent echoing
but um yeah so
gonna do jack reacher all right
um this had been recommended to me on
one of the other shows in live chat yeah
like a while back i can't remember who
said something about it but then
everybody was like yeah you should see
the jag reach her once i think that
might i think that might have been louie
that was talking about this series
i'd never heard of it
i've never heard
evidently there's books and everything
so yeah there's a [ __ ] ton of books and
they've only sold like 100 million
copies yeah i didn't know
[Laughter]
anyway
i liked it it was good it's basically uh
tom cruise is batman
but he's without the suit
real similar and without the [ __ ]
money he had money but he didn't have a
job he was homeless
he was living off his pension and
and nobody could find him because he had
erased his identity he only dealt with
cash and he just he didn't even he just
bought clothes and threw him away he was
done with him he didn't even have any
bags all right what i didn't uh what i
didn't understand though was that he
still lived on his military pension but
it's like if to get a military pension
you still have to have like a bank
account and an address yeah yeah but
then he would take it to western union
or something like that and have it no i
think he hit it
did they explain that maybe they they
sent it they sent it to they sent it to
western union he turned it into cash
okay so i think that's how it happened i
don't think he had a bank account
yeah because i was thinking i'm like
well to open a bank account you have to
like yeah he had it rigged up where he
was totally invisible
nobody
he's paranoid
but he had powerful enemies it turns out
he was uh
like a
an ex-military
uh master detective he was a cop like an
mp uh and he was just you know he just
said a lot of [ __ ] it was [ __ ] funny
that you know if your ex military you're
like oh yeah right because yeah but you
know you civilian cops you know you deal
with murders murderers but all my
murderers were trained killers you know
because they're all in the military yeah
so it's like
yeah
right
and then uh turns out you know he's
dealing with real corrupt [ __ ]
corporations and [ __ ] in the military
industrial complex and everything so he
he's got to be totally [ __ ] invisible
and because he's an investigator
he knows how to hide
and uh
it was a good movie it's a good movie it
was kind of
um
what the hell that's my phone it's your
phone it was a notification it was kind
of uh i want to i don't want to say say
me but it kind of was say me you're all
you know what i mean
yeah i was going to say it's very tom
cruise tom cruise but if you like that
yeah if that's what you're looking for
then that's what
in the beginning of the movie
this crime goes down
and then uh the dude who committed the
crime
um
asked for jack reacher
and uh the the investigators on the case
were like uh who's jack reacher and then
they pulled his file and [ __ ]
and uh they just name off all this
[ __ ]
high speed
this dude
yeah and he goes he and then they start
naming off all his [ __ ] medals and
[ __ ] and like some of them are so rare
they have to look them up and
they're going on and on about this
dude's [ __ ] credentials and i go oh
that could only be tom cruise okay that
could only be tom cruise and of course
you know
tom cruise jack reach
he's like yeah that's me pretty much
yeah
i also i'm amazed they didn't say he's
also won like the nobel prize yeah right
yeah oscars and golden globes
whatever the hell else
pinewood derby yeah i don't know
what's funny is you know
guys that have guys have been you know
have served and [ __ ]
a lot of the real impressive sounding
medals
you know i mean to a civilian you know
they you can read into well what what
must have happened for him to get that
medal
and
during
during times of war you could just read
you know dude's [ __ ] his jacket you
know his dd214 is just filled with all
kinds of [ __ ] a lot of times
and then you see the dude he goes that's
him you know what i mean
and um
a lot of the stuff some of the stuff you
know dude technically wasn't in combat
you know
just the one the the one that was the
the
if a dude is alive and he's got the
[ __ ] congressional medal of honor
with whatever kind of device on it is
very rare usually those dudes are dead
the one that really meant something was
stuff like [ __ ] bronze star
bronze star silver star
uh [ __ ]
they had the other one there was one it
was got an aviation one or was it called
[ __ ] not
some kind of cross knight's cross not
knight's cross i don't remember there
was some good [ __ ] that you know like
door gunners and [ __ ]
apache apache pilots or apache gutters
that get but i forgot what that was
called but uh i don't know
i don't really give a [ __ ] when anybody
models battles
i think the funny thing about it and
this is probably coming from the books
too which i think i read one of the
books like a really long time ago but i
kind of like looked into like research
them i think i've read more of cause lee
child the guy that writes the books
um he also does books with uh what's his
ass uh douglas preston i want to say
like i've like with um
what's this what's the name of that like
creepy like almost vampire like print
pendergast pendergast okay i've read a
couple of those i think i read one of
the jack reacher novels like many many
years ago because somebody loaned it to
me so um can we say
i don't know if this is entirely
accurate but i feel like the tom cruise
character in this or the jack reacher
character maybe in the books as well
would we call him a mary sue yeah yeah
yeah that's what i was thinking because
like when
when they you know come when he comes in
they're talking about him like before he
gets there yeah and they're like listing
off his accomplishment i'm like this
[ __ ] is good at everything like
everything he can do it and he's like
not shy about telling you either yeah
like he'll totally come in and like
condescend to your ass because he's like
way like he's better at fighting he's
better shooting he's way smarter than
everybody he's just kind of like so i
was kind of like this is like a mary sue
right he is although is like the male
equivalent is gary stu is it is it not i
think it is yeah but yeah he's a total
mary sue
but i think that mostly like comes from
i don't know i thought it was kind of
funny i wish they had kind of like upped
the humor on that a little bit
i mean if this does have funny [ __ ] in
it but not like funny hot like out right
i don't think i don't think cruz would
have allowed who would have allowed it
to become kind of like a parody that's
what i'm saying but that's probably why
you're supposed to take this [ __ ]
serious it's kind of like ethan hunt
from
mission impact that's what
it seems like the almost a similar
character and okay so what i didn't know
now
i i feel like most people know like if
you read books at all but lee child has
written i don't even know how many jack
reacher novels there are it's a [ __ ] ton
uh and it sold like hundreds and
hundreds of millions of copies jack
reacher is like a beloved character now
the books
are kind of like i saw like somebody
compare them it's like they're kind of
like those old school like men's
adventure
novels where they're like super over the
top and like the guy is like i'm the
best at everything [ __ ] he's one
of those types of so it's like a fantasy
kind of thing yeah now when this for
when this movie first came out in 2012
like the novel that it's based on uh
came out in 2005 and it was called one
shot
but
um when the novel first came out and
they or when the movie first came out
and they announced that tom cruise was
gonna play the part
all the fans of the books freaked the
[ __ ] out because one of the defining
features of jack reacher in the books is
that he's a big [ __ ] giant
muscle-bound dude he's six foot five
he's like 250 pounds he's this big
[ __ ] and he's so and he's not only
that like he's just this big beast of a
person
um because he's supposed to represent
like a force of nature kinda uh oh and
he's also like i said best of fighting
invested shooting he's also a math
genius like he's kind of like so he's
good at everything yeah um somebody said
i can't remember what book it was but
somebody said something that made me
laugh they said one of the books and
they're like and i i [ __ ] you not
actually has a scene where a bullet
whereas bullet is stopped by jack
reacher's peck okay yeah
i was like no and he's like no seriously
seriously he's like that's the level of
the book it's like it's funny it's like
supposed to be over the top but it's not
like combat like i said it's like a male
fantasy
like alpha male fantasy kind of like
books like those old like men's
adventure things and those dudes never
read those kind of books
vicariously through that [ __ ] he's
usually in all the guys you know
armchair guy armchair commander well
yeah they're so so they're just like
supposed to be fun yes you know same
guys who who read
western novels back in the day uh right
the male equivalent of
uh the old lady reading harlequin like
bodice rippers yeah harlequin romance
novels well i i don't like those but
yeah it's kind of the same kind of
really you know yeah it's like something
but it's like that same concept yeah
yeah like i said it's like a male
fantasy kind of yeah but like i said um
you know they they seem like a lot of
fun yeah so when it was announced that
tom cruise was gonna play the character
everybody was like no he's like a little
he's like a little bitty guy yeah he's
nothing like yeah
um you know what i mean and then lee
child was kind of
you know being diplomatic about it and
he's like yeah fine i think they were
talking to dwayne johnson first yeah
which is more like the the closer and
they said had they made these movies
back in the 80s it would have been like
arnold schwarzenegger sylvester stallone
or somebody like that he's like a big
bulky dude yeah um sly wasn't big enough
so that's the slow one well what they
did and i didn't know this until we
watched this movie and i was like
researching it but amazon has an
original series because lee child always
said well he's written so many books
about this character that they really
kind of need a series to like expand it
out because he's had so many like
adventures and cases and stuff
and so he's like well it should do a
series so actually starting
it it just came out february of this
year so just like a couple months ago
and they did a season one of uh of jack
reacher and they got i can't remember
the name of the actor i've seen him
before but i can't but he got the got a
big [ __ ] bulky dude he's not quite
6'5 i think he's 6-3 but he's like a big
muscular and they said he even put on
like 30 extra pounds of muscle like to
play the character because he wanted to
look like this big beast and they said
that it kind of like that like kind of
accords better with the guy from the
novels and they said actually the series
is a lot more violent than the movies um
like you probably would and like i said
it's on amazon prime so you can watch it
um the first season is up and it
apparently like people are liking it a
lot um they said yeah it's a lot more
violent and they have like a lot more
room to like bring in elements from some
of the other books and like other cases
that he's and kind of get a little bit
into his backstory and stuff like that
so apparently like people are really
liking it but yeah i didn't realize
i mean i just thought like i said i
thought this was like another tom cruise
like action vehicle which he does a lot
of those
so and it does kind of come across like
that it's still a good movie yeah but
it's it doesn't really like stand out
from some of his other ones like it's
like the mission impossible ones or some
of the other like or almost like
collateral yeah or like collateral
because i mean jack reacher is not
necessarily a bat he's not a bad guy
he's not really a good guy but he's not
really a good guy either i mean he just
kind of like he operates he seems to
have like honor but he but he kind of
like doesn't really worry about what the
law is kind of like the punisher
yeah the punisher but you know uh
although you know there's been a bunch
of different interpretations of the
punisher
um
but he's kind of like that but he
happens to be an investigator too so
in the way of kind of like batman being
a private detective you know figuring
out you know where where guys are coming
from and figuring out who's a patsy and
this and that but he was just pulling
[ __ ] off the top of his head because i
know what's going on he'd even have to
he could look at the evidence and just
look at it and understand exactly what
it'd be like every single cop has been
working on that kid you guys are stupid
yeah like figure this out although i
have to say
that
i mean i kind of figured out because if
you don't know like at the beginning of
the movie there's like a sniper and it's
in uh pittsburgh and he just like goes
out and like takes out like five random
people and then they're saying something
about like the quarter and the parking
and everything like that i'm like well
this is obviously a frame up like that
guy didn't [ __ ] do that so the fact
that he comes in and says yeah it's a
frame up and they try to figure it out i
was like well that wasn't that hard to
figure out and you'd think like the cops
would have figured it out beforehand but
then there's like i'm not gonna like
spoil what happens in case you haven't
seen it but
you know what i mean so he uh hooks up
with the
somebody asked like who's the blonde
chick in this and what does she do
she's um that's rosamond pike right she
plays
she's an attorney she's like the da's
daughter yeah right and then she's
trying to so she's defending the sniper
yeah and her dad is [ __ ] crook he's a
crook
but actually he's not really a crook he
just told her not to [ __ ] take this
case and ruin her career because they're
all corrupt
well and because everybody like they
didn't really know
you know what the deal with the sniper
was and they were just kind of like well
nobody wants to defend this scumbag
because he just like killed like five
random ass people
so he was like ruining you know that's
funny yeah so it's just kind of like
that
but yeah i mean on the whole i actually
kind of like this but you can very much
tell
i mean from what i've from what i've
read about the books it's a lot more
toned down
than the books and it's not i don't
think the books are necessarily supposed
to be funny
but they're kind of like
i don't know if they're kind of like
wink wink like there's just super over
the top but they're just supposed to be
like super fun and exciting and read
stuff like this when we were kids right
right right there was one that there was
a series i read it was [ __ ] badass it
was called traveler you can still get it
and it was like maybe you told me about
it it's like mad max it's like mad max
and the punisher it was post-apocalyptic
as an army ranger guy running around in
a damn dune buggy fighting [ __ ] the
remnants of the us army and they were
all [ __ ] up and they were the bad guys
and he ends up hanging out with a
genetically engineered
animal human hybrid dude named lynx
who's [ __ ] the uh
little links he can talk and everything
he's popular with the women a [ __ ]
his [ __ ] bizarre man it was good he
started fighting other cars and there
was these send cars they were biological
centaur things that had wheels like cars
and bone and
giant [ __ ] rhinoceros that could be
bipedal it was a good series
called traveler but it was over the
[ __ ] top and it was it was like when
you said jack reacher he'd get out of
anything
you know yeah and there was like about i
don't know probably about 40 issues went
on for a long time
yeah that kind of stuff like it's like
wish fulfillment that's like that's like
stuff that it's like hey i'm just going
on vacation
and you just want to read something
that's like kind of fun and breezy or
i'm just going to read it on the
airplane or whatever like just kind of
like take your mind off [ __ ] yeah
one thing one thing about traveler
though you guys could look it up you
could probably still get the he the army
had injected him with uh some kind of
[ __ ]
super soldier serum that made his uh
uh senses really good you could see in
the dark and he could detect things he
had like spider sense
and
he could get badly injured and heal up
real quick
in a way kind of like wolverine
but it made him crazy though too
i hate when that yeah it made it crazy
he was insane for years he woke up and
the the world had changed and he didn't
know where he was and he tried to find
all his
army buddies who had been injected with
that [ __ ] too he eventually finds them
one by one but anyway or the ones that
had lived it was a good series camp guy
said john grisham novels read like that
too total pulp fiction yeah i kind of
feel like there's a lot of
you know a lot of real popular novels
that read like that slasher fred said
one of these days you should review the
jack ryan movies including the 1990 film
the hunt for red october
yeah that's right harrison ford played
jack ryan in several movies yeah it's
just like there's tons and tons of these
and i can't even remember like all the
authors names but
that are all these kind of just like
intrigue kind of novels like political
intrigue or corporate intrigue or you
know spies and [ __ ] like that there's
like tons of that stuff is like always
like real
real big sellers you know what i mean
but yeah so these books in particular
like i said they've sold like
bajillions and bajillions but everybody
was just kind of i think once people saw
the movie they were kind of like oh he
was okay in it but i think they were
still kind of like disappointed so i'm
you know i'm thinking the series
probably people were happier about that
now one thing i will say is that tom
cruise as he usually does did all his
own uh stunts in this so he did all the
driving and all that kind of stuff
he did all the acting too he did all the
acting too
amazing
can we talk about you know what this
movie needed more of though that werner
herzog yeah he was good in it
herzog creepy [ __ ] played kind of like
the main bad guy i guess i mean he
wasn't really the main antagonist in the
sense that he was always he was kind of
like the shadowy
like big boss you know what i mean
um
so i so i love that he was in it because
her dog is creepy as [ __ ] and so he was
like so he was creepy as [ __ ] i didn't
like that
the way that like his character was
wrapped up it seemed a little
anticlimactic i will say that
um i did like robert duvall in this
turning up is like the gun store owner
that was just kind of like we were gonna
go like shoot some people and he's all
like [ __ ] fun and everything that was
like pretty cool he's trying to get back
into action yeah
that was like super fun yeah but yeah i
mean this like i said it was a good
movie
um but it was just like another like tom
cruise yeah action vehicle if you like
that kind of [ __ ] then you would like
this i kind of feel like the more i
looked into the books yeah i was just
kind of like oh i'm glad they made a
series that seemed like closer to the
books because that actually sounds more
interesting yeah just in the sense that
he's like a lot more distinctive
character right he's not just like
generic tom cruise action guy yeah he's
actually like a big bulky [ __ ]
fighting dude but he's also like a math
genius and all this other kind of like
who can figure out like he's sherlock
holmes right uh you know but al but in
this big huge like [ __ ] so i was like
that's kind of that's interesting that's
like an interesting character and
somebody that like that you know that
stays off the grid and like just turns
up i mean the funniest scene
to me and like i totally called it too
because remember at the beginning
because when they the guy like the the
the purported sniper is in the coma
and he wrote down on the piece of paper
like get jack reacher and they're like
what the one of them said who's that and
they're like i thought that guy didn't
exist or he was just a legend or some
[ __ ] like that and then they were like
well how do we find him and then the guy
says oh i don't think you find him i
think you find him and i'm just like
wait for it
and then he shows up and i was like
called it yeah because he was just gonna
like hi i heard you were like i
psychically knew that you were calling
me i was like that's like what a badass
he is there's this there's this one
scene where this uh
young
chick [ __ ] sits down across from in
the bar and immediately asks to ask him
to go outside with her and go [ __ ]
make out in the car and he's like neat
has her peg does a hooker and then she
gets mad and then like seven dudes
[ __ ] rise to defend her and
it was all the setup he takes them
outside and [ __ ] whips all their
asses and [ __ ]
and uh most of them were bigger than him
now the choreography was pretty good
they made it kind of kind of believable
that he could do what he was what he did
um
i mean
war machine was only 170 pounds and
[ __ ] he could be he could fight a
whole group of dudes outside a bar
and get him to run
uh but you know so i guess he did that
but it would make more sense if he was
like he said six foot four
yeah and he would just go but here's the
truth about that
dudes that are six foot four and just
[ __ ] built like that nobody [ __ ]
with them not even in the group
you just yeah you would think i mean yes
that ended up being a setup very
obviously and he like knew immediately
because as soon as that girl comes over
because i said a random woman is not
going to come over and sit an extra
strength and be like hey babe unless
she's a hooker yeah exactly see so you
know so he called that like that doesn't
happen in real life no
so um so he knew that it was and then
when the other guys came over he's like
oh i see what this is so he
automatically played the whole thing was
a setup because that's what he was going
to do but you would think that whoever
like um when they did the setup if the
dude was like he was in the book that
you'd think that they'd send like a
bunch of big bruisers like somebody more
like his side right yeah where whereas
these guys were kind of like they were
they were bigger than him but they were
kind of like average size yeah
[ __ ] right um oh i did like the
one scene where werner herzog like um
told that other guy to chew his own
fingers or he's going to shoot him it's
great i think that was probably my
favorite because it was just the bullet
i don't understand it
and then like i'm i'm totally over that
i wasn't even drinking when we were
watching this movie i'm totally like i
wonder could you do that and i'm like
sticking my fingers in my mouth against
you i'm just like
i don't know how badly do i not want to
get shot could i could i actually like
chew my fingers off if i had to i
thought about that for like way too long
depends on your will to live i guess
i mean
you know so werner was just kind of like
well i guess he didn't want to vote
because he had to chew he he had to chew
off his own fingers because we're
sitting there going why are you chewing
off your thumb bro like chew off your
pinky you don't need that but i guess he
had to chew off the same fingers you
would think that if you pulled a gun on
somebody and says do this or i'll shoot
you then they'll go then they'll do it
but no there's
thousands and thousands of videos of
cops pulling guns on dudes and the dudes
just rushing the cops
nah you know what i mean and supposedly
a sane guy an over a damn
parking violation or something there's a
lot of people that are irrational that
just would rather be shot
and killed than to submit
and just yeah so or maybe they don't
think the guy's gonna shoot him maybe
maybe they think that it's like they
can't really like conceive yeah that
they would get shot that would just be a
sign of just massive massive ego and
solipsism that well yeah i can't be
killed the world exists because of me
and i i wouldn't doubt that some people
probably do think that yeah maybe that
was the first thing that i jumped they
won't shoot me and then the [ __ ] cops
just plugged the dude and you punk dirt
dies you shot me while you're doing this
you shot me yeah
i told you i was going to yeah there's a
lot of it on a lot of it on youtube's
just channel called police activity
and very impartial police activity yeah
police activity channel
bizarre [ __ ] that's what i that's what i
call pookie's daily routine i call it
pookie activity yeah
she goes from activity to activity
that's why i laughed because i was just
kind of like gadget 3 says everyone is
bigger than tom cruise by the way yeah i
mean pretty much and the one scene like
i said when the when the guys like go
out of the bar and he's gonna like whip
all their asses and he's but he has to
make a speech first it's just kind of
like well you know this one's the leader
so i'm gonna kick your ass first and
then i'm gonna kick that the second end
command's ass and then they'll always be
two guys they're gonna run away and blah
blah so he has this whole like situation
worked out which of course is what
actually does happen but when they do
like a long shot of him like standing in
the middle of the dudes you can actually
really tell like how small he is yeah
compared to the other guys yeah tom cru
no one's quite sure what how tall tom
cruise is i've heard five six i've heard
five seven
although i kind of feel like five eight
i think it's designed to claim five
eight i think no way i think they
claimed five eight no way you guys could
look it up what do they how tall they
say he is
i think he i think they say five eight
but there's no way
and
you when you see him next to uh to david
miscavige
he's he's bigger than david miscavige
but david miscavige might only be about
five three i think david miscavige is my
height and i'm five foot three yeah five
three and i i would i have tom and i
don't know what kind of shoe game he's
doing because there's a shoe game he's
got like some big fragrance
monster [ __ ] there i think i think
tom is five six
see that's what i suspected yeah and in
fact somebody was even making a joke
like in the comments of like one review
of this that i was saying they're like
they're like well maybe he read that the
jack reacher character was six foot five
but because he's dyslexic
but because he saw five six he's like oh
i'd be perfect and i'm like mean but
probably like that's probably true and
like i said i don't have a i don't have
an issue with like dudes that are short
and stuff like that but it just does
five six yeah he's five six two so it's
just kind of like i don't have an issue
with that it's just i think people had
an issue not just because tom cruise is
short obviously nobody has an issue with
that because he's a zillionaire and he
makes a zillion movies still but
i just think that they thought well he's
not jack reacher he's not that character
he's nothing like he's described in the
book
so i can see that but i think he did a
good job but like i said i kind of feel
like it was too
generic and
again that little smugness
i don't think it would have bothered me
as much if it was like some big giant
dude and he wasn't he was more like
stoic but tom cruise like i said he has
that natural cocky yeah asshole-ishness
yeah and so everything that he says it's
like oh i'm correct about everything and
i know everything and you don't and so
like when he says it like that he always
comes across as like really smug and it
just makes me want to smack him in the
mouth yeah and i [ __ ] repeat
you know what i mean i've told this
story you know people [ __ ] people
[ __ ] recommend
tom cruise movies to us because they
know i want to talk about tom cruise
yeah
kind of like the way i don't
kind of like the way they try to get me
to talk about [ __ ] stevens to go
although we we generally do not watch
steven seagal yeah because they most of
them are just boring as [ __ ]
i got resp i got a lot of respect for
tom cruise okay he actually is skilled
he can ride motorcycles he's pretty good
he's pretty good with guns
uh and he did all his own driving does
his own drive all the driving he can fly
scenes and all that [ __ ] he can fly
aircraft and uh you know he takes a big
interest tom cruise really they they
[ __ ] give him what what they would
call in uk abolican
bollocking
[Laughter]
mostly mostly i think it's a cross
between
scientology and [ __ ] talking
but his [ __ ] talking isn't like direct
[ __ ] talking it's that jumping up on
oprah's couch type [ __ ] talking
it's just something but in his defense
oprah and the female audience seemed to
be eating that [ __ ] up that he was doing
yeah
a lot of the [ __ ] stuff comes from
his association with scientology which
is very unethical [ __ ] but i
understand how scientology works it's a
cult it's kind of got a paramilitary
tinge to it
and it turns a lot of people off but
understandably so
uh just because what what happened to
there's victims the way they treat
children you know they treat children
like adults they lock people up in
religious prisons yeah it's hard it's
it's [ __ ]
hardcore but they're not playing around
um
they leaked uh scientology leaked a
video of tom talking about scientology
and he's given a message to other
scientologists that only scientologists
really know how to fix problems like
when there's a car crash hey
scientologists take care of that not the
ambulance
not paramedics but science but see
that's kind of that's kind of the energy
i was getting from him in this movie
yeah yeah like i'm the best i know
everything i'm here now i'll solve all
the problems yeah it looks you're
welcome it looks very it looks hilarious
to us
from a non-scientology point of view but
he's just trying to talk up and motivate
scientologists so everything had a
different he's a pr man he's an actor
and uh the church wanted him to [ __ ]
rile up the the audience of
scientologists so he was you know he's
giving him a good blow on him you know
basically blowing
literally blowing them blowing the
scientologists
[Laughter]
lining them all up
making them feel good about themselves
gotta fluff them
[Laughter]
but
so
the only [ __ ] the only stories that i
think are
kind of legitimately kind of [ __ ]
strange about tom is that
tom doesn't seem to ever
turn off
he's always on he's always the tom
cruise
that you see on his persona yeah
and uh when he talks to
regular people and other actors and
stuff just in a mixed crowd he kind of
comes across as being on like he's on
stage
and uh that he's kind of
trying to be a normal person like you
guys
but he doesn't really know how to he
can't just chill out hang out that's
what they say yeah see i get that i i
very much get that five right he can
very much get that vibe yeah he's like
that he's got to be on he he very much
seems yeah he seems like
all surface like like he's kind of fake
and he just always came across like
that's me even like before i even knew
about all the scientology [ __ ]
[ __ ] he always came across like that
to me and like i said he always comes
across as like smug
and even if he's being like super nice
and everything like that you always get
the feeling that he thinks he's better
than you right what he's doing because
he's a trained scientologist
which is has a pair paramilitary tinge
to it
tom is doing what's called command
presence it's the presence of the
persona that you put on when you're in
front of your troops
okay
so he's with around other actors and
he's like hey how are we all doing
aren't we all doing good today so it's
almost like a corporate slash military
meeting
it's not
it's not
yeah it's not it's not you know you know
exactly what i'm talking about yeah it's
not an actual friendship or an actual
relationship or
it's not even very professional it's
kind of just like
live action propaganda all right and
it's because he's dealing with
non-scientologists
they're wags that's why that's what they
call them logs
gotta watch because in the uk though
that means that's a racist slur yeah
scientologists call
non-non-scientologist walks
which is condom
means kind of like mundanes or garbage
or something like that it's it's it's a
derogatory term
to an uh it's like calling somebody a
dummy
so he's
goes into a command presence and tries
to uh
it's a form of manipulation really
and keeping people at
arm's length he doesn't trust them so
he's going to put on the mask
i don't think he's well integrated with
normal people i mean [ __ ] the way he
grew up how could he ever have
kind of like just a normal
friendships with people he's surrounded
i think by scientologists most of the
time or he's in heidi well and you know
and plus he's like a superstar and he's
super super rich which obviously like
isolates him from his fellow man but
then there's like another layer of it on
top of that
so i would be very shocked if he could
actually just like hang out and act like
a normal person now some
ex-cultists in scientology say that he's
kind of just say
one who was it what's her name described
him as diabolical
leah remini leah no
yeah it was leo no wasn't leah remini
it was um
karen karen de la carrier said that he
was diabolical that that's how he's
really he's that he's not a
which uh
basically they're talking about is like
a high ranking commissioned officer
that's been around and [ __ ]
commanded lots of [ __ ] people because
he does that they'll command people to
work on his car and [ __ ] you know i mean
because they use scientology as
scientology's partly tom cruise you know
i mean you can get them to [ __ ]
modify all his vehicles and change the
interiors and [ __ ] kind of like
slave labor in a certain way well it's
exactly like slavery yes
[Laughter]
so he's used to being in command of sea
org personnel and stuff
which is kind of like a military command
the sea org is kind of like a
man i've been getting off on [ __ ]
scientology well yeah um but yeah it's a
part of the movie
that little dude tries to boss me around
and kick him right in the nuts
[Laughter]
yeah so he would be superior to you in
any relationship
he's talking to you
he's better than you
yeah see that has always come across to
me that he's like obviously thinks it's
like well i'm clearly yeah it's so much
superior i would just think it was funny
though
cause i [ __ ] punch that [ __ ]
we got the short guy thing coming he's
fair game
[Laughter]
yeah we're just saying that yeah so
nobody could like accuse you of like
picking on somebody's problem yeah
[Laughter]
usually short guys click
so he probably would probably click and
i started [ __ ] with him and he'd say
some sea work [ __ ] and then i'd [ __ ]
throw some army ranger [ __ ] at him and
[ __ ] oh okay and i started [ __ ] with
the lrh like a [ __ ] out around however
you know he's like oh and if we get into
it and i'll punch him
tom's already got it he's got it all
planned out no but i'm just [ __ ]
around because i actually like i
actually like l ron hubbard i don't
believe him i think i think he's full of
[ __ ] but i thought i thought he was a
master storyteller there was good movies
about him uh
and the cult liked him he was
fairly nice to them he was popular with
the cult i don't think he was a bad guy
he just went crazy i don't
know prove what he did with his families
but you know yeah that was [ __ ] up a
lot of guys have [ __ ] up relationships
with their ex wives and ex-wives fourth
throwdown says tom cruise is actually
two guys in a trench coat
[Laughter]
well thank you we got a super chat oh
boy did we really yes we did
finally danny rowling says mimi rogers
said their love life was like being
married to a monk
yeah wouldn't surprise me yeah that
sounds about right i don't think his
guard has ever dropped i don't think tom
cruise ever drops his guard yeah i don't
even know if there's anything of
substance underneath there
gadgey3 thank you very much just for
cheek short guys can still kick ass
maybe not me these days though
i mean yeah so
um somebody asked if we were going to
review the second movie yeah jack
reacher never go back sure i'd watch it
uh that came out in 2016. yeah i'd watch
it now the weird thing about it so the
first movie even though like fans of the
books kind of bitched but it did like
make a lot of money i don't think it
made quite as much as they were
expecting because i think it was
supposed to be like a whole franchise
like the mission impossible movies this
might even be the same director as some
of the mission impossible movies now
that i'm thinking about it i'm not
entirely sure but yeah it was gonna be a
whole franchise but i think like then
the first one didn't make quite as much
as they were expecting and then the
second one came out and i think that
didn't make quite as much either so they
were just like [ __ ] it and they just
decided not to do it anymore well like i
said they started like the series so
people seem to be like much happier with
that
but you know i've seen like little clips
of it and it does kind of look more like
what i was picturing
you know when people were talking about
the books i'm still laughing about that
um stopping a bullet with your peck
though yeah i mean
yeah somebody said that because like i
said i was i was reading an article
about the comparing like the books and
the
movie
and somebody there was like all these
comments of people that have read the
books and talking about how fun they
were and they talked about i can't
remember what book it was but they said
yeah he literally accepts it while it
was packed yeah like i laughed and
laughed and i'd like to know what
caliber that was supposed that he was
supposed to stop because standard [ __ ]
people i think it was a 38 because i
think somebody asked that
well 38 i think if i remember correctly
i don't know what bullet could think
because i was like laughing really hard
competing
depending on bullet configuration and
weight you know you're talking about
something on par with nine millimeter
nine millimeter full metal jacket
can go through probably about i don't
know maybe 20 depending on the barrel
length maybe 20 something inches of
ballistic gelatin
that's like three rib cages
well yeah obviously this is just kind of
like and then somebody like the next
person said oh it would have been way
funnier if he'd actually like bounce the
bullet off and like shut the cat
that'd been like way more yeah you're
not stopping
with your pekka toys yeah
even 22 long rifle will [ __ ] go into
your turtles oh that'd be [ __ ] there
you're not going to stop well that's why
somebody brought it up is like an
example of like these are the kind of
books we're talking about so like
clearly that cannot happen but that's
just like what uh what a badass this
dude is he can just like control he
doesn't even have to have the bat suit
on or anything the weakest thing
commonly out there would be 25 acp
and that'd go through a pack
i think that would even go through a rib
cage after a thick peck
yeah
but see that's why that's why these
books are like male escapist fantasies
because they're like here's this big
[ __ ] hulking [ __ ] who's good
at everything
he can even bounce [ __ ] bullets off
his titties i mean come on 25 acp out of
a sub compact pistol like a little baby
browning or something if there's not
much barrel there
has pissed off a lot of guys
you know being shot with that but it's
killed a lot of them too about half of
them they don't know where it hits
but it never stops the bullet that they
stop in you
yeah it'll be
just not what you wanted but not in the
pack
and it's not real destructive it's kind
of
most of the time the wound similar to
what an ice pick wound would be so i'm
saying don't carry that
you're likely to piss somebody off if
you shoot it with that
you take that thing from you shove it
right up your ass
better be a head shot and even that i
have to be above the eyeballs yeah
here's the thing like when i was when i
was watching a thing about the series
and they were talking about how much
more violent like the series you know
just because closer to the books and
then i was thinking back to the tom
cruise movie and i was like yeah that's
really not all that violent was it it
might have just been pg-13 yeah it
wasn't that violent
it was a fun movie yeah it was fun yeah
it was a fun movie i was i enjoyed it i
thought it was a good movie i thought
tom was good in it i thought yeah you
know it's just it was just a good
standard and you know look i'll all
[ __ ] everybody's tried to make a few
bucks [ __ ]
[ __ ] with tom cruise and making fun
of tom cruise i i respect tom cruise
um he's he's a good actor
he's good at what he does he people go
to see his movies to see him that's he's
a brand you know and
you pretty much know what you're going
to get if you see tom cruise he's got
the number one movie right now
yeah that's what i mean he's still
[ __ ] making movies
like after all these decades over a
billion dollars all right um
we still haven't seen it um
yeah we're probably still in the theater
we need to get off our ass and go to the
because i want to see black phone too
yeah but see the thing about i was gonna
say oh we should go see black phone but
i want to see it in dolby and the only
dolby showing is at 10 30 p.m yeah but
i'd be i'd be [ __ ]
[ __ ] tickled pink if i was [ __ ]
tom cruise right now with the how much
top gun too is kicking ass
i mean tom cruise can [ __ ] bring it
if he's got the right movie it's the
right thing yeah i mean like i said he
started out in the [ __ ] 80s yeah you
know what i mean and he's still going
strong he can still do [ __ ] stunts he
can still do all that [ __ ] and he's
still like yeah brings all that money
and like for movies people are still
going to see him so you know
so you just gotta respect that that
angle so he doesn't give a [ __ ] if
people say you short and he didn't give
a [ __ ] people [ __ ] with about
scientology and being a [ __ ] snotty
[ __ ]
for all i know if you catch him in the
right day the right situation [ __ ] he
might be [ __ ] he might be awesome
it's
it might be that he just has to be on
around certain kinds of people
i just thought of like something
terrible what if what if we were like
driving around one day and we got an
accident in the only person that came by
to
up help he's resuscitating me
well he doesn't he's just like he's just
going yeah
he's just trying to do like scientology
magic i mean like touch assist he starts
giving me a touch assist and [ __ ] and
i'll [ __ ] come back to life
and he goes i saw yeah
[Laughter]
all right tom
you're coming on the show
all right we're gonna tell this story
all right
we're gonna tell the story and [ __ ]
your shit's you're gonna you're gonna be
smelling like [ __ ] roses
over man [ __ ] you were right you're
right you're [ __ ]
what uh your your ot powers are are true
yeah we're gonna tell everybody yeah and
then he's gonna say yeah well i stopped
the space time continuing backed up and
[ __ ] heard once i heard that this
happened to you and then i [ __ ]
backed it up again and took a plane to
show up here to intersect with this
[ __ ] car accident because because of
what you said on that show
just to show you know what i mean that'd
be a [ __ ] trip
i was like
[ __ ] oh my god we should make that movie
yeah
yeah let's start let's start on the
screenplay like right now yeah maybe we
could actually get tom cruise to be in
here and playing himself then i become a
convert and i start [ __ ] going
through the [ __ ] bridge of freedom
you know what they call it the bridge to
happiness what'd they call it the bridge
the bridge to total freedom bridge of
total freedom right yeah and i have to
[ __ ] just sell everything to make ot9
or ot8
you know i'm robbing banks to get the
money
to get all my ot powers
[ __ ] hilarious oh my god
i kind of i would totally watch that
movie yeah i would totally watch that
movie but only if he would like to write
it right now we could only write it
together yeah we'll just write that [ __ ]
together and then we'll get him to do it
yeah because he has to be in it like
yeah yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
maybe we can get scientology to bankroll
it we could get them to bankroll it
because it would be like scientology
propaganda yeah i get to touch assist
[ __ ] wake up
tom cruise and he goes yeah
yeah
slaps the [ __ ] out of me
what the [ __ ]
said you said you're gonna beat my ass
tom cruise treat me like a [ __ ]
oh my god
i want to see this movie so bad now
we need to make it yeah i'm gonna have
to i'll just make it on my phone
[Laughter]
we'll get a cup we'll get like a
cardboard cut out yeah have tom cruise
just like my one of like uh mirror
universe back there yeah
and then we'll just have like and then
somebody can do the voice i can't do the
voice but then after all that [ __ ] like
[ __ ] like
a couple months later i'm like i fall in
love with tom cruise
and then the sequel is like a love story
yeah
[Laughter]
you and tom cruise go camping yeah and
he and he can't quit
and here's the thing man he can't quit
and then he goes
he goes to [ __ ] he he goes uh to
auditing right and he tells him
then all right yeah during his audit he
tells them about what happened and then
they start using him they start using me
as dirt to control him yeah i got like
man and i gotta save him from
scientology oh my god yeah and then he
becomes c.o.b
afterwards
david
we overthrow david miscavige and [ __ ]
tom cruise this is like a whole trip
yeah we can make a whole trilogy right
holy [ __ ] right
[ __ ] ridiculous man we just like man
like this is like printing money [ __ ]
that movie would make millions
it would it would out do top gun
probably
it would
if he came out with some [ __ ] like that
yeah he'd top top gun top gun too get
outside i should like write i should
write some like chuck tingle-esque like
novels where i should write them like
that but it's like i could change tom
cruise's names lately so that he can't
sue me yeah but that everybody obviously
knows that it's him and then maybe then
someone will option it and like a
trilogy yeah david bowie's in it
somewhere somehow
hey he was in the david lynch movies he
was in the swimming pool you
it's just [ __ ] weird i mean when he
was doing those glass balls like he's
like glass balls up here glass balls
down here
i don't know how he started talking
about david bowie's balls but you know i
mean that's how that [ __ ] happens that's
how that [ __ ] happens
yeah so that's probably about it yeah we
went for like an hour i can't believe we
came up with a whole like tom cruise
trilogy just while we were sitting here
god we're [ __ ] geniuses we're
geniuses i'm telling you right now all
right
so we're going to take off and go get
something to eat i guess because i'm
kind of hungry yeah
but
tomorrow we're going to be talking about
should we spoil it it's just this movie
that we just randomly came across yeah
on amazon was on amazon prime right yeah
like um free to me yeah yeah you can
watch it it's good it's like a
post-apocalyptic movie yeah and i was
like oh it has peter dinklage in it yeah
it's called i think we're alone now yeah
like the tiffany song although that was
a cover wouldn't it yeah it's a
post-apocalyptic movie
it's like a drama it's not really a
horror movie no everybody dies in some
kind of they don't really say but it was
some kind of weird pandemic yeah i don't
think they know and there's a town of
you
had 1600 people and only one dude
survived it
and peter dinklage yeah
he's a dwarf
well everybody yeah well i didn't know
he's never even heard he's a little
person he was on game of thrones and
he's been in tons of [ __ ] he's taking
care of the town and burying all the
dead and he's been out there for a long
time well don't spoil it and then one
day this damn beautiful girl shows up
and he didn't want anything to do with
her it's weird you know but then
it gets
you know what is this movie about it
takes a while
for you to realize what the movie is i
really dug it i mean it's a slow burn
and like i said it's not really a horror
movie it's post-apocalyptic but it's
more like a drama yeah
um
but kind of reminded me a little bit of
boyd his dog not not quite as zany and
action-packed but it's just
this good movie yeah it was really
interesting it almost could be in the uh
in the stand
universe of stephen king yeah we kind of
thought that maybe that's what it was it
might have been that
yeah gadget three says i'm five foot
[ __ ] all but back in the day i could
kick the [ __ ] out of mofo twice my size
at the football yeah i was one of those
bellends
yeah the biggest bell end is one of my
very favorite like british insults by
the way the bit the biggest the biggest
weapon that a short guy has is that if
you beat
a if you beat a dude's ass and he's
taller than you his name is mud they
can't lose to you so that's like getting
beaten up by a girl it's like you it's
not that bad
it's not that bad
it's just they don't they don't they
don't want it's like one level out from
you they don't want to get they asked me
to buy a short dude
[Laughter]
what would happen if you got your ass
beat by pookie i don't know
[Laughter]
that's way down the [ __ ] thing
all right so yeah so we're gonna be
talking about that movie tomorrow which
like i said was actually really good and
we just came across it randomly
so
we'll be back tomorrow to talk to you
guys so have a good rest of your day
thank you for the super chat and we'll
see you guys again tomorrow